[Music]
there's a man
who's convicted of stealing 1.2 million
dollars worth of fajitas vaginas that's
a that's a lot of that's just meat right
like chicken fajitas or steak fajitas
how much is 1.2 million that's a lot
dude he was heisting [ __ ] fajitas
though damn was this jojitsukawa
that makes me hungry i like carasadas
better do you
so i'm not that much of a vagina guy
this is for resale dude this is not
where's the thing but they got steak
fajitas here's what sucks though i don't
get hype if you get the fajitas
and you just say steak they cut it for
you if you get the carne asada you gotta
cut that thing for [ __ ] 17 minutes
sometimes mother especially when it
folds over when it folds over in the
u-shape you're like god [ __ ] damn it
but i think it's a different cut of meat
that's why
flapstick yeah they use flapper carne
flap is a funny word vegeta's
i just made that up to to make myself
feel better about the differences in me
so he does more experiential for me is
all i know because when you go though
yeah like exp yeah in terms of like when
you go there and it goes on the sizzle
so that's why i would never be able to
eat fajitas if it's like to go same oh
yeah that's true i tell chili's i'm like
uh no i like it authentic it comes on a
sizzling plate that's right
how do you want chilies to go i'm like i
like authentic i'm gonna eat mexican
food tonight so
yeah let's not get it twisted
so this guy he lived um in a place
called cameron county
which is in san benite ben san benito
san benito it was in texas oh
i was like i've never heard of that in
california i was like benito of diego
yeah
san bernardino
the beautiful side he he was um employed
at the daryl hester juvenile detention
center in san benito he was working
at the juvenile hall yep and while he
was there he heisted
millions of dollars worth of fajitas
[ __ ] that must be a lie
from the catering company that's the
government food oh just over the years
over the years he was just stealing dude
fajitas is on the juvenile detention
center menu that makes me want to go to
jail oh me too i thought they have
shitty food fajita fridays it's called
lucky orphan tuesdays maybe i don't know
that's taco tuesdays no no i know but
sometimes they do it on tuesdays because
of the mexican thing one of my
co-workers um because mexicans eat on
tuesdays
day mondays too they do that they
mondays
my one of my coworkers his family ran a
catering company that was uh doing a lot
of government [ __ ] and then one of his
things was for the jails and so he would
bring jail snacks that was left over
gushers
it was literally like peanut butter
jelly like sandwiches and [ __ ] that you
could make it just the peanut butter
jelly comes in a pack ropes
sour patch kids you know i love a nerd
bro you could make your own little thing
and i was like dude this is [ __ ]
crazy i mean [ __ ]
jail food right now i like it when they
uh you watch the videos of people trying
to smuggle [ __ ] into the jails by using
peanut butter jars and spinning the [ __ ]
out of it are you seeing those dude i
love watching people make prison food oh
yeah that is it that is my favorite kind
of content is the best [ __ ] in
goodfellas dude spaghetti they use they
use coffee creamer to like make ice
cream and [ __ ] and ice like it's
actually pretty genius how they do it
wow and it was sliced the garlic really
thin with the razor blade resourceful
but uh vaginas right vaginas
so this is the whole thing right so he
over nine years he just keeps on
stealing more fajitas right
and then this guy like you know he's
like i'm in too deep it's crazy
he's like i'm still 24 years i don't
even know who the [ __ ] i am you know how
many wait how much facilities have you
stole over the years 1.2 million dollars
worth yes
what got so bad where he would he would
just be at like you know
any of the the mainstay mexican
restaurants and he's sitting there and
he's like
i don't know who i am anymore like what
the [ __ ] am i doing he probably doesn't
even order fajitas because he's like
i don't even know the value of fajitas
anymore because i get it for free you
know like he takes it for granted he got
jaded you got jaded with this vehicle do
you think he started supplying the local
restaurants with fajitas that's probably
why i know he did right i know he did i
know for a fact
just to clarify one more time for my uh
idiot right now when you say somebody's
stealing fajitas they're just stealing
the meat no they're stupid the seasoning
so anthony maybe okay so maybe okay how
do i put this in there yeah
so here's the thing so imagine this is
like a sizzling plate of faces
okay this is being heisted before it
goes to the table every plate does that
make sense to you so so then the bell
peppers the onions so then the chili's
waitress
has to come out and say i'm so sorry we
don't know what happened to your face
at the juvenile hall right and then and
there's kids there just just standing
and they're waiting for the fajitas so
they can just [ __ ] have a bib on like
it's like this they have their fork and
knife and they're ready to go oh they
have a baby they give them nice and
they're all in the gym we want fajitas
we want fajitas it's tuesday that's the
mexican day where we could eat mexican
foods
the chili's waitress is like sorry not
tonight no fajita pitas is fajitas is
that considered tex-mex
i think so is that considered tex-mex
exclusive can we call geo right now yeah
can you call it real quick hotline can
you actually call her we need an
official mexican texas very important
they love it's very very good who knows
because just
geography geo just asked what he
deserves as an ambassador of mexican
food he doesn't have her number by the
way no i do he doesn't have her number
he's like looking for her do you know
her number she's going to call him put
on speaker
what's the question
specifically technically i preface it
like it's something seriously
do you know any other mexicans you could
have been dying right now i would be so
embarrassed can you just call any other
mexican that would be anthony's rubbing
it i would be so excited
okay are fajitas text mess or not all
right let me let me call you you gotta
hear her i'm gonna call this timer you
guys want my wife looks pretty mexican i
can handle this but she does my wife is
salvadorian so i can't ask her because
that's the thing that's just jill's
brother jio's brother all right see if
he picks up his face dude you know what
i know someone better call jill's mom oh
yeah yeah yeah that's a really good
source you know yeah that's true because
jude is in cook she's pretty much she's
pretty much mexican i mean like the
mother of mexico
jew was born here she's like taco bell
but she was not on the border you know
not exactly more taco bell she's more
inland you know for sure
this whole family is unresponsive
what did you marry in june yeah dude
this is kind of it's that boost mobile
dude that's how you want to make it
hey ma this is an emergency in mass
emergency are you ready
is our fajitas mexican
what our fajitas mexican i need to know
there's a gun next to my head right now
he's gonna blow my [ __ ] brains out if
i don't know if fajitas are mexican is
it mexican
that's a no
yes you know what you can do with your
question what
find it in the encyclopedia
okay but you're is that a mexican book
yes
okay
but now that i have you on the phone ma
can you please tell me if fajitas are
mexican because this guy's gonna blow my
brains out let's go you [ __ ] sucker
[ __ ]
that's the guy with the gun
isn't it it's a big gun okay what what
kind of fajitas are we talking about the
the fajita fajitas
chicken chicken just chicken chicken
fajitas
boil boil fajitas
you know what boil is right ma
i think so okay so our pollo fajitas are
they
mix and match fajita treat are they
authentical
mexicano or not
i'm not gonna answer because i don't
want to get involved in you guys stupid
conversation
[Laughter]
thank you thank you that's a that's a
ridiculous accusation
is the mix and match fajita trio mexican
or not she's just like blow his brains
out
get rid of him
okay thank you okay bye okay so we
didn't get a clear answer that's awesome
i think that's a no dude so not to ask
my [ __ ] white wife
[Laughter]
i think there's a conspiracy
there's mexicans that all say yo we got
a good business going on these [ __ ]
gringos don't know [ __ ] yeah you know
let's just not tell them because the
japanese association i'll tell you guys
this the insider secret is california
rolls is not real sushi that [ __ ] was
made up in california
i used to think i love sushi until the
philadelphia rolls made in philadelphia
it was invented by
you're pretty good dude by philly
hori nochi
that was the that was the name
filihorinoci in
philadelphia um
so he's still a japanese guy yeah and he
invented it in the california role was
from california richard yamazaki
and um
first name is the middle
the california i don't know why they
decided to name him that that's his
nickname oh callie rich
cali rich yama california yeah hey are
volcanoes from volcanoes yeah so the mix
and match fajita trio
has
chicken carne asada
and shrimp i did not know that that's
pretty funny that sounds delicious are
shrimps mexican
yeah yeah of course huh so it's like the
serpentor ceviche
it's actually yeah it's like it's like a
yeah it's a surfenter
of the mexico you just go to chile's
fort if you want it's in the water
should we get chilies today
choice to go sounds let's do it no
feeders though no fajitas because we
need the sizzling plate oh
it's like they only do when you're joe's
brother gonna call you back now you're
gonna be like don't worry no i don't
think that only real we're only wrong
not enough
it only wrong not enough that's the
question
she left yeah hey we'll do it off the
record about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you